what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to a study that i found
that's insane before i start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel ring
that notification bell please
um and for real subscribe because
i'm trying to get to 25 000 subs and i
know a lot of you watch my videos
and you don't subscribe i'm like like
what are you doing
okay sorry
okay so a study says 50 of women in
relationships have a back-up partner
we are often advised to have a back-up
plan for everything in life
in case whatever plans we have don't
work out
seems reasonable
it seems women are taking this advice
very seriously because as a survey
conducted by one poll a survey-led
market research company
specializing in an online and mobile
pulling fifty percent of women in
relationships have a plan for a backup
partner in the back of their mind in
case their current relationship doesn't
work out
and they head for a breakup read on to
no more okay with blah blah
um the backup person is mostly an old
friend
around a thousand women from the uk
that's where i live now
participated in the survey and almost 50
percent of the participants both married
as well as unmarried women admitted to
having a backup plan or person to fall
back on in case they separated from
their current partner a substantial
number of participants stated that their
backup person is most likely to be an
old friend who had romantic feelings for
the concerned women in the past so
basically if you're in a women's woman's
friend zone
she's keeping you as a maybe if i try
every single other person
and that doesn't work out
then yes
i'm in the uk so i'm drinking tea
which i need to stop doing i found out
that stains your teeth more than coffee
like
okay
he could also be an ex-boyfriend
colleague other participants of the
survey also stated that their backup
person can be anyone a colleague
ex-husband school friend or man she met
at the gym what is important is that
person has to be someone she has known
for a long time who would be ready and
waiting to be with her if the need
arises so this is
my
advice to anyone in the friend zone is
to let her know
that you will not be ready and waiting
and to make it very clear that you will
be moving on
um
and make her choose
a person who would drop everything for
her around ten percent of women 1 out of
10
who participated in that study stated
that
their plan b revolved around a man who
might at some point and time have
confessed feelings for her
five percent of women participants were
con confident that the other person
would drop everything to be with her
when required
do you guys think he would if what if he
was in a new relationship you think you
both guys would let me know in the
comments if you were in a relationship
and that girl that you always wanted was
like look
she she was she came to you and said
look i'm ready to give you everything
you've always wanted for me she's better
looking than your current girl
has more qualities than your current
girl has but your current girl has been
down for you from the since the
beginning
you gonna drop her
honestly would you
i'm just curious you think men are as
hypergamous as women because i think
about that a lot
okay are there current partners aware of
it
what came as a big surprise is most of
the participants shared their other half
or their current partner or shared that
their other half or current partner
knows and is aware of the third person
although the partner has no idea about
the backup plan one of four women
participants said her current partner
has met the third person
uh the plan b and a surprising number
twenty percent one in five revealed her
partner or husband is friends with the
other man in her life
oh my god
this makes me if it wasn't thanksgiving
i would call my mom right now and be
like mom
do you have a backup plan for dad
um
yeah i
okay a spokesperson of the research
company called the findings a worrying
sign and said that social media sites
have made it easier for women to stay in
touch with an old flame however it's too
early to rise the alarm because this was
not okay basically it says this they
didn't survey enough people to make this
study valid like apparently you need
like a thousand people or something but
this is crazy like
i'm trying to start saying like it less
so comment on my video every time i do
it from now on okay
but that's crazy
i definitely as a girl know the feeling
of having a guy friend that would like
date you if given the chance
but a backup option oh my gosh married
women
wild let me know in the comments what
you guys think
um
stay woke guys i just had to show you
that article stay woke
don't forget to subscribe i'll talk to
you later